the other thing I want to just say about
the third [ __ ] it's dinner is when was
it it written or how was it planned
because it seems so kind of perfectly
placed now it's very kind of zeitgeist
even in that kind of trumpian
America John misko's character is almost
a version of trump exactly I was a tall
plant not the scary part is that there's
so many like him yes we were thinking
about the dentist that killed a lion
yes and so it was before Trump but when
we were shooting he was campaigning but
now I won't ask you about your political
opinions but we do the picture but yes
but you're not gonna ask me because
you're you already know with a lovely
pinata
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the minute he started talking about the
Mexican two days later we were selling
pinata somebody brought one to a party
at my house
the Mexicans lined up worse than the
little kids and the tragic thing was
that the first person that went on it
killed it in two seconds but some people
were stepping on it on the floor oh yeah
what was he like strange like I mean one
thing you gotta give it to him like he
is what it is it's not like yes he's not
pretending this is what you have you
know I have no but you did you did take
the opportunity of dressing up as him
[Applause]
Halloween and it was my Halloween
costumes before he was the president and
I thought well you know what's the
biggest nightmarish figure in today's
culture and I thought on top and not not
for a moment did we think it would
actually become president no you must
have thought I'll do it this year
because next year to wash that off
afterwards just out of interest because
that is quite them of them are three or
four weeks but this week Donald Trump's
been on his first trip abroad as
president so here's some pictures of him
away here is in Saudi Arabia now that
was going on there well apparently it's
some sort of peace thing but it doesn't
look like a crystal ball doesn't it yep
I see impeachment I see disgrace mystic
it's not really doing any favors oh he
then went to Jerusalem where he visited
the Western Wall and he placed a note
inside
certainly the note was for the wall
builders call me I've got a job
you know Victor you got he can't even
touch a wall appropriately by the way if
anyone's wondering what that unusual
thing on his head is that his hair is my
favorite picture from the trip on free
season on Wednesday
arania Villani looks like he's got a
funeral
you see when Trump tried to hold
milania's hands in protecting the
Bellagio store and actually talking of
world leaders David recently noticed a
resemblance between yourself and another
world leader yes
well I saw a picture of our glorious
leader to resume and in use I think she
did actually look a lot like me I think
you've got the picture I do we do
that is shockingly close he's weird
how I could play Bionic
you